herzlich willkommen zur hallo
deutschland haben donnerstag und
natürlich auch zu unserem heutigen
kroner kompakt wir zeigen ihnen wie sie
sich beim einkaufen vor viren schützen
können wir begleiten einen müllmann
unter erschwerten bedingungen in diesen
tagen und professor strikt der direktor
der virologie am bonner uni klinikum
beantwortet live ihre fragen los geht's
die meldung aber von heute wegen des
corona virus stellt das helios
krankenhaus in münchen pasing seinen
normalen betrieb ein
35 patienten und zwei mitarbeiter der
klinik wurden mittlerweile positiv auf
cupid 19 getestet der shutter und beruht
auf diese maschen anstieg und natürlich
auf die ursachensuche und wird dass
nicht klar ist
[Musik]
insbesondere die befunde der mitarbeiter
die jetzt noch ausstehen ist aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht weitere
patienten zu gefährden jetzt sind mal
die türen geschlossen worden
konkret heißt das patienten werden
wieder aufgenommen noch verlegt noch
entlassen
die infektionsketten sollen so
unterbrochen werden ich denke dass wir
insgesamt leben in unserem ganzen land
und auch natürlich in unserem klinikum
im kleinen ist schon eine große
solidarität ein zusammenrücken ein
bewusstsein dafür dass jetzt alle an
einem strang ziehen müssen dass wir
diese krise bewältigen müssen
die krise bewältigen dabei kann auch
musik helfen
[Musik]
da
die klänge com aus aachen ein udo
jürgens klassiker neu arrangiert von
feuerwehr und polizei
die klare botschaft helft einander
unglaublich was positives
[Musik]
die gibt es nicht
kreativität auch beim thema schutzmasken
die in diesen tagen oft schmerzlich
fehlen
zur not tut es aber auch eine unterhose
das geht einfacher als gedacht
auch ohne nähmaschine das kroner virus
breitet sich weiter in deutschland aus
allerdings leicht abgeschwächt
inzwischen meldet die johns hopkins
universität 79 1465 infizierte 19.000
175 menschen gelten als genesen und mit
diesen zahlen gehen wir jetzt mit dem
wissen um diese zahlen in den ort gange
den heinsberg vielen wird der erst seit
dem ausbruch der cholera epidemie etwas
sagen aber hier gab es den ersten
schweren fall eines corona infizierten
wir würden zuerst die kitas und die
schulen geschlossen
und genau hier will man jetzt den virus
noch besser auf die spur kommen
eine schule auf dem platten land in
gangelt direkt an der holländischen
grenze
die schüler haben corona frei nun nutzen
der kreis heinsberg und die uniklinik
bonn die räume für ihre studie
der kreis stellt diese bilder selbst zur
verfügung schottet die etwa 1500
teilnehmer ab die alle aus dem 12 1500
einwohner zählenden gangelt kommen in
gangelt fand die karnevalssitzung statt
auf der sich vermutlich viele menschen
infiziert und dann das virus verbreitet
haben
ein 70 köpfe zählen das team um den
bonner virologen hinrich streek arbeitet
an der studie
in den letzten wochen haben sie schon
viele haushalte von infizierten besucht
abstriche gemacht blut und auch
luftproben genommen
auf der suche nach dem virus der test
den der landrat stellvertretend zeigt
besteht aus einem fragebogen etwa nach
vorerkrankungen oder krankheitssymptomen
einem rachenabstrich und auch einer
blutprobe findet man antikörper ist klar
dieser mensch war schon infiziert
wichtig zur feststellung der
dunkelziffer und damit des sterberisikos
von kogit 19 ja- und den mann dem wir
gerade gesehen haben beitrag beim
blutabnehmen den direktor des instituts
für virologie am universitätsklinikum
bonn
der ist uns jetzt live aus gangelt zu
gestalten hallo herr professor hendrik
strikt hallo wie gut kommen sie denn
voran und wann könnte es erste
ergebnisse
dort geben nun wir haben ein bisschen
start schwierigkeiten wie das immer bei
solchen kugel studien ist die natürlich
auch in über nacht eigentlich entstanden
sind aber die ersten beiden tagen war es
ein bisschen holprig aber heute läuft
alles wie geschmiert die studenten sind
wirklich extrem motiviert ja auch
schnell lösungen mit finden zu können
und wir werden von den gangelter von den
heinsberger hier unheimlich gut
aufgenommen und bringen kuchen vorbei
oder verpflegung also es richtig nett
hier und wir hoffen dass wir ende
nächster woche zumindest die ersten
vorläufigen ergebnisse haben und was
versprechen sie sich von denen was sind
die erwartungen im kampf gegen die
pandemie nun einmal wollen wir verstehen
wie die dunkelziffer aussieht also
sprich zu verstehen wie viele menschen
hier eigentlich infiziert waren und sind
ohne eigentlich davon zu wissen es wurde
ja nicht jeder getestet und nicht jeder
aufgerufen getestet zu werden sondern
nur eine kleine ein kleiner teil der
bevölkerung und wir haben jetzt eine
repräsentative stichprobe gezogen
zusammen mit dem kreis heinsberg der
verwaltung vom kreis heinsberg
und haben die eingeladen jetzt zur
blutentnahme und zum abstrich zusätzlich
gehen wir zurück zu dem ursprung dieser
infektion also der der kappensitzung der
karnevalssitzung und wollen verstehen
nicht nur wer sich eigentlich infiziert
hat und warum aber uns interessiert auch
warum sich einige menschen nicht
infiziert haben und was die anders
gemacht haben im vergleich zu denen die
sich infiziert haben
wir sind gespannt auf die ergebnisse und
ich sage erst mal vielen dank professor
strikt auch dafür dass sie ihre wichtige
arbeit dort und das kuchen essen noch
ein bisschen unterbrechen und ruhen
lassen um später mit uns hier die
zuschauer fragen zu beantworten also bis
gleich forscher auf der suche nach
erkenntnissen pflege an den
krankenhäusern lieferwagenfahrer und
supermarktmitarbeiter sie alle sind
beruflich gesehen
systemrelevant wie es so schön heißt
genauso wie die mitarbeiter der
müllabfuhr und auch die arbeiten gerade
unter erschwerten bedingungen mehr müll
weil mehr menschen zu hause sind dafür
allerdings weniger einsatzfähige
kollegen wegen krankheit und quarantäne
wir haben ein müllwerker mal begleitet
aus potsdam
robert vize ist einer von 280
müllwerkern in potsdam
hygiene ist ihr job nicht nur in diesen
tagen lebensnotwendig robert vize und
seine kollegen sitzen zu dritt im
fahrerhäuschen und tragen deshalb
verantwortung füreinander angst vor
infizierte müll haben die müllwerker
aber nicht draußen bin ja nicht so viel
mit menschen in kontakt komme gerade
jetzt in wohngebieten und wenn dann geht
man schon bisher auf 28 stunden am tag
lehrern die männer eine mülltonne nach
der anderen
seitdem die menschen so viel zeit haben
müssen die müllwerker deutlich mehr
schaffen als sonst die leute viel zu
hause sind
das müllauto fast zehn tonnen klingt
zwar viel aber derzeit ist der wagen
deutlich schneller voll als gewohnt eine
umstellung für die müllwerker in der
tonne können wir noch zu laden aber die
auswahl war relativ schnell in der
zentrale versuchen planer michael kucera
und geschäftsführer burkhard greif
währenddessen die entsorgung auch in den
kommenden tagen sicher zu stellen
50 mitarbeiter fehlen derzeit bisher ein
krankenstand wie während einer normalen
grippesaison keinen direkten corona
befund gehabt wir haben vier kollegen
auf präventiv erstmal zu hause gelassen
weil die über fünf verschiedene ecken
auf einer versammlung waren und da wurde
jemanden auf corona positiv getestet die
haben wir dann sofort raus kommen aus
dem bereich der schutz der mitarbeiter
hat im moment priorität denn ohne eine
funktionierende müllabfuhr haben
deutschlands städte ein problem wir
können einfach nicht mit führungen
planen wenn aber jetzt auf einen schlag
20 30 leute halt wegen corona
ausgenommen werden müssen
sie ist natürlich anders aus
mit dem gedanken spielen jetzt erstmal
nicht wir haben zwar ein plan b den
humor ist aus der schublade wenn es
wirklich darauf ankommt kam es den tag
aufs neue die turnhalle zu besetzen so
dass der posten und bürger beruhigt arms
ein so ich das
robert vize und seine kollegen müssen
weitermachen das ohne menschen wie sie
nichts läuft wird vielen erst in der
krise wieder bewusst
genau diese erkenntnis lässt sich auch
eins zu eins übertragen auf das
arbeitsfeld von kai reinheimer der ist
nämlich landwirt und wie viele seiner
kollegen fragt auch er sich mehr oder
weniger täglich wie er genügend
erntehelfer bekommt das ist ein großes
problem in dieser krise aber in dieser
krise gibt es ja auch ungewöhnliche
hilfe es ist eine arbeit für menschen
mit guten augen und gutem rücken das
unkraut herausreißen und die kleinen
rote beete pflanzen stehen lassen und
die die das hier tun sind echte anfänger
in sachen landwirtschaft zum beispiel
lisa kerstin doreen die drei
friseurinnen waren auf den hof von kai
reinheimer gekommen nachdem sie dieses
video gesehen hatten es ist samstag 18
uhr
ich bin seit 15 stunden jetzt in meiner
firma versucht lebensmittel zu
produzieren versucht meinen laden
aufrechtzuhalten mir fehle 70 prozent
des personals ich fahre einfach irgend
jemand ob er mir helfen kann
35 rumänen arbeiten normalerweise bei
ihm jetzt fehlen sie keine einreise
wegen corona der erste truppe kam noch
im bus ist eine grenze abgewiesen worden
dann hieß es okay es gibt die
möglichkeit der linienflüge samstag
sonntag komplett im internet herum
geforscht die papiere fertig gemacht
passierscheine alles mögliche also da
waren drei leute komplettes wochenende
beschäftigt die leute endlich
eingestehen musste der aufsteiger
aber dann standen sie da sonntagmorgen
um 8 fast 100 freunde und bekannte
fremde kunden kumpels aus dem
sportverein und eben auch die drei
friseurinnen
der bauer der ist direkt um die ecke und
ich glaube und gerade in so zeiten
müssen wir alle füreinander da sein ich
glaube schon dass es wichtig ist sich
untereinander zu unterstützen auch
gerade die kleinen gewerke müssen sich
unterstützen weil es schon schwierig ist
gerade jetzt im moment der caj brauch
uns wir helfen egal dann machen wir das
jetzt und wir haben halt alle auch
darauf gepocht ok viking auch endlich
mal den kopf wieder frei
solidarität gemeinsinn und vielleicht
sogar freundschaft familie reinheimer
war und ist überwältigt die
menschenmenge zu sehen die ja wirklich
einfach innerhalb von einer nacht das
organisiert hat und hier aufgetaucht ist
das war unglaublich war wirklich schön
zu sehen wie heute kartoffelsupp gekocht
für alle jede stand mit seinem
sicherheitsabstand da und hat sich schon
erhalte und auf aber fingen die leute an
sich zu applaudieren
also mit mir nicht irgend jemand der was
geleistet hat dass man sieht sich selbst
und man hat eigentlich nur in strahlende
gesichter guckt und das war
überwältigend das gefühl dass ich klicke
jetzt schon wieder gänsehaut und
eigentlich wäre jetzt alles in bester
ordnung wäre da nicht dieses
eigenwillige wetter der spargel erfroren
die radieschen zu klein der schnittlauch
zu spät dran und auch der salat ist noch
lange nicht so weit wie er sein sollte
so wie das jetzt aussieht wächst im
moment gar nix und ab nächste woche wird
es warm dann schießt alles und dann
fehlt uns dann auch einfach die zeit die
leute an zuweisung des wird bis sie
chaotisch wir erwarten davon niemanden
dass er direkt hier da super mitarbeiter
wird einfach fragen und dann passt das
ganz gut also die euphorie ist trotzdem
immer noch da weil wir wirklich für jede
person dankbar sind landwirtschaft eine
arbeit für menschen mit guten augen
gutem rücken und guten nerven was das
einkaufen betrifft in diesen tagen da
kristallisieren sich zwei typen heraus
die einen den kurzen besuch in einem
supermarkt als willkommene abwechslung
sehen zum zu hause sein und die anderen
die am liebsten gar nicht erst hin gehen
würden denn was es mit möglichen viren
auf dem einkaufswagen zum beispiel oder
auf verpackungen hat sich alle an den
sicherheitsabstand deshalb ein paar
tipps wie sie sich beim einkaufen
schützen können
es hat sich so vieles verändert beim
einkaufen in diesen tagen
man wartet draußen denn im geschäft soll
nur wenige kunden sein und scheiben
trennen nun verkäufer und käufer
dennoch fährt die sorge vor einer
ansteckung mit dem corona virus oft mit
im einkaufswagen ein paar grundregeln
können da helfen dass man nicht zu nahe
an andere personen heran kommt also
möglichst diese 1,5 bis zwei meter
abstand halten
wenn ich an der kasse anstehen sowohl
von der kassiererin als auch zu der
person vor mir es geht ähnlich schneller
wenn ich jetzt von hinten drängen
also da die zeit und die hohe mitbringen
etliche hände berühren einkaufswägen und
andere griffe in den läden lauert hier
also die große ansteckungsfälle also das
virus ist auch flächen nur sehr kurz
haltbar das heißt auf der clip auf dem
griff von dem gefrierschrank den ich auf
mache oder auch wenn ich den
einkaufswagen schieben ist die chance
sehr gering sie ist aber nicht nur das
heißt ich würde einfach empfehlen wenn
ich nach hause komme vom einkaufen was
ich mir als erstes mal die hände dann
habe ich alles was da dran ist weg und
dann ist auch das risiko wieder weg
frisches obst und gemüse sind ein fester
bestandteil der gesunden ernährung doch
gerade äpfel oder salat werden oft in
die hand genommen und begutachtet ein
nährboden für die viren erstens würden
die auf dem obst nicht sehr lange
überleben zweitens wasche ich mein obst
sowieso immer ich glaube das macht jeder
weil man alleine die spritzmittel und
das was da drauf ist runter haben will
und selbst wenn ein virus drauf wäre
wird es damit auch runter gehen solche
bilder sieht man nun immer häufiger
menschen gehen nur noch mit mundschutz
zum einkaufen
es hilft sagt die expertin aber nicht so
sehr um mich selber zu schützen sondern
wenn ich infiziert bin um andere zu
schützen weil wenn ich dann lese dann
spritzte es halt nicht durch die welt
sondern bleibt da drin hängen dieser
mund nasen schutz der held schon mehrere
stunden
der darf halt mich feucht werden wenn
der feucht werden dann verliert den
schutz das heißt dann sollte man den
abnehmen vielleicht am zweiten haben was
ist an der kasse mit geld das
tausendfach von hand zu hand geht
virologen sehen das eher gelassen denn
auch auf scheinen und münzen könne das
corona virus nicht lange überleben
am sichersten sei jetzt dennoch die
kontaktlose bezahlung per karte corona
viren sind hoch ansteckend aber sie sind
eben auch empfindlich gegen jede art von
seife tenside putzmittel
die sind aber auch empfindlich gegen
höhere temperaturen wenn ich essen koche
das heißt ich hätte es auf über 60 grad
dann habe ich das virus auch ganz sicher
kaputt abstand halten
direkte kontakte vermeiden und immer
wieder hände waschen
es sind denkbar einfache regeln sie aber
können helfen das risiko einer
ansteckung beim und nach dem einkaufen
gering zu halten und ich weiß jetzt
nicht auf unser heutiger corona kompakt
expert überhaupt noch zeit hat zum
einkaufen grad aber was ich weiß dass
die professor entdeckt strikt vom
institut für virologie an der uniklinik
bonn zeit für ihre fragen nimmt
hallo zum zweiten mal her strikt wir
legen am besten direkt los und keine
zeit zu verlieren willi kohl hat gefragt
in hochhäuser mit 50 oder mehr wohnungen
sind ältere menschen oft auf den aufzug
angewiesen wie groß ist da die gefahr
einer infektion also man kann das so
pauschal nicht sagen das hängt davon ab
auch wie viele menschen in einem aufzug
waren wenn man natürlich ganz eng
gedrängt ist und es ist eine einen an
hustet dann besteht das schon ein wenig
risiko aber man kann sich auch darauf
berufen erstmal die häufig wurde das
sind schon mal gezeigt in der
vergangenheit gab es schon mal
infektionen im fahrstuhl wurde das hat
er schon mal jemand darüber geredet und
das gab es bisher nicht
also wenn man sich da jetzt nicht laut
unterhalt der held das husten und niesen
vermeidet dann ist ja eigentlich auch
kein risiko
notfalls eine fahrt aussetzung warten
bis wieder leer ist adolf loos hat uns
geschrieben und erinnert sich dass sie
früher ganze räume von viren und
bakterien gesäubert haben mit uv licht
kann man das auch gegen korona time
einsetzen
ja man kann also auch promovieren sind
sensibel gegenüber uv licht aber das
kann man nur bedingt einsetzen man kann
ja auch nicht die ganze straßen oder
menschen bestrahlen mit uv-licht das ist
jetzt kein gangbarer weg und damit würde
ich sagen ja theoretisch kann kann sowas
verwendet werden aber es ist jetzt nicht
ein etwas was wirklich praktisch
anwendbar ist
in der folgenden frage von udo den sinn
geht es direkt um das virus im körper
und zwar möchte er wissen ob man corona
jahre lang in sich tragen kann auch ohne
dass es ausbricht
nein dass es bisher nicht gezeigt worden
für irgendeinen corona virus also wir
kennen ja mehrere korrigieren das ist ja
eine familie und da wurde nie gezeigt
dass sich irgend eine längere also auch
eine chronische infizierung handeln kann
mit neuen corona virus das neue corona
wir uns kennen wir ja noch nicht sehr
lange und wir können nur diesen zeitraum
auch überblicken aber da gibt es auch
keine berichte darüber dass sie jemand
mehrere wochen oder monate mit dem virus
infiziert ist
ihn kennt es noch nicht lange es gibt
auch noch keinen impfstoff und genau
darauf bezieht sich die frage von detlef
s wenn dann endlich mal einer gefunden
wird ein impfstoff wie lange dauert es
dann noch ein medikament herzustellen
ja also impfstoffforschung und
medikamentenforschung sind ganz
unterschiedlich und auch wenn man
vielleicht ein
medikament hat heißt es nicht dass man
einen impfstoff hatte und andersherum
wenn man impfstoffen heißt es nicht dass
man unbedingt ein wirksames medikament
hat das problem bei medikamenten ist
meistens das man dass die in der
frühphase der infektion bei viralen
erkrankungen gut wirken also wenn man
zum beispiel eine grippeinfektion hat
dann in den ersten stunden und tagen der
infektion dann wirken die grippemittel
wenn man die erst später in der
chronischen schweren phase nimmt dann
wirkt es meistens nicht mehr so gut und
daher kann das auch mit neuen corona
großen problemen sein dass die
medikamente er früher wirken aber nicht
spät also ich kann da keine vorhersage
sagen machen wann wie einen impfstoff
oder ein gutes medikament haben weil da
die forschung einfach immer von
überraschung ja immer wieder neue
überraschungen hat eine letzte frage
haben wir noch einen europa hat
geschrieben ich glaube das können sie
kurz beantworten weil wir schon darüber
sprachen
im ausland werden die ganze straßen oder
außenanlagen desinfiziert passiert das
auch in deutschland und bringt das was
nein ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
das in deutschland passiert das virus
ist nicht sehr stabil und daher muss man
auch nicht straßen desinfizieren also
das ist er glaube ich ein ein grund
bilder zu erzeugen und zu zeigen man
macht was als dass es wirklich eine
effektive maßnahme ist oder sinnvolle
maßnahme sinnvoll ist aufklärung so wie
sie das gemacht haben vielen dank
professor streek für ihre antworten und
auch viel erfolg bei ihren wichtigen
untersuchungen dort brunner kompakt
bereiten wir täglich neu und aktuell vor
und laden ist dann auch immer direkt
hoch bei youtube sie finden es dort über
den kanal der zdf heute nachrichten für
die morgige ausgabe haben wir die
psychologin ulrike lücken eingeladen die
dann auf einige ihrer fragen antwortet
also wenn sie etwas wissen möchten
einfach eine mail an corona kompakte zdf
de schicken